thank you nate now if you're tired of
club quarantine
and not ready for casino crowds there's
a luxurious exclusive establishment
right off the strip
that you can escape to let's head to the
sterling club
welcome to the sterling club the
sterling club is a beautiful
private exclusive social club right in
the heart of the las vegas valley just
off the strip
right from when you first drive in our
guard gated community
you walk in the valet knows your name
you can actually get your car
detailed here you come in you can get
your hair cut by michael boyce
colored by michael boycek our spa is an
oasis
you come in you can get any sort of
treatment you can get a stone
treatment you can get a facial our
estheticians have been in training for
25 years
our lead esthetician is a chemist
creating her own products for our club
then you can go up and have a beautiful
lunch executive chef dan rossi
is amazing you could go out and play
tennis on our har true clay tennis court
some of the only clay courts in las
vegas
then you could play a game of pickleball
you can come in you can work out
we also in with our membership includes
our pilates and our reformers pilates
and our
yoga we have many different different
types of massages we have couples
massages
we have athletic massages after you play
a game of tennis you can come in and
have them rub you down a little bit
we have any type of massage you could
ever want we will create one for you
our pool is something you can come enjoy
you can run a cabana we have cabana
rentals during the week and the weekend
and it is such a reasonable rate when
you're a member
and it's private we have food and
beverage out at the pool we have
djs we have night parties or we just
have relaxing time where you can sit and
read a book and
and hang out and relax zone out the
sterling club is an amazing way to
socialize
safely in these times one of the aspects
are
is the cigar lounge the cigar lounge you
sit you can have a cocktail
you can have a glass of wine cognac go
to you we have humidors for cigars
it builds camaraderie and i've seen so
many business wonderful business deals
being accomplished in the cigar lounge
also we have a supper club
which draws in amazing talent throughout
the city
skydee miles has performed here chase
brown has performed here
so it's something to behold other
aspects of the club with social
activities are we have an amazing new
nightclub
open on fridays and saturday nights
bottle service for members
is a hundred dollars a table we have
everything you can think of when it's
someone's birthday or somebody buys
extra bottles the ladies come out with
sparklers
it's a true nightlife experience we do
amazing events
we do weddings we can do anniversary
parties birthday parties
graduation parties with that comes
exclusive member pricing of being a
member of the exclusive sterling club
i'd like to offer everyone a 10-day
trial membership and come see what the
club is about
because there is something for everyone
here
i mean i'll take the trial membership
that place is just
incredible yes i know i know okay so you
can visit the sterling club right on
2827 paradise road for more information
just call
to 702-732-9700 or just head to the
sterling club.com
there's more las vegas now coming up in
less than three minutes don't go